Trascrizione: Lucia Girotti
Revisore: Rossana Cantaffa
In realtà di cose sull'Universo
ne sappiamo veramente parecchie,
sappiamo, per esempio, che tutto
ha avuto origine da un Big Bang,
circa 13,7 miliardi di anni fa.
Sappiamo che l'Universo si espande,
da qualche anno, sappiamo anche
con che velocità si espande,
sappiamo come evolve,
sappiamo che evolve nel tempo
e abbiamo capito molti dei meccanismi
che stanno alla base della sua evoluzione
e siamo persino
riusciti a misurare
quanta materia e quanta energia
sono presenti nell'Universo.
Sono cose assolutamente stupefacenti,
straordinarie,
il nostro cervello non si è evoluto
per questo motivo,
quindi è anche abbastanza sorprendente
che siamo riusciti a capire
tutte queste cose.
Però, appunto, oggi vorrei raccontarvi una
delle cose che noi che cerchiamo di capire
come funziona l'Universo,
ancora non abbiamo capito del tutto,
ovvero del suo lato oscuro,
il lato oscuro dell'Universo,
che, ovviamente, non è questo lato oscuro,
ma è questo.
C'è una parte dell'Universo
che noi non vediamo, non si vede,
e non si vede perchè è fatta di qualcosa
che non assorbe luce, non emette luce,
non riflette luce,
e in realtà non solo la luce,
ma nessun altro tipo
di radiazione elettromagnetica.
Quindi sarebbe in realtà più corretto
parlare di lato trasparente dell'Universo,
ma "lato oscuro", evidentemente,
per noi cresciuti con Guerre Stellari
era più minaccioso, e quindi era
un po' più efficace come termine.
È una componente dell'Universo che
non riusciamo a vedere normalmente
con i telescopi, ovvero con lo strumento
che hanno sempre usato gli astronomi,
ormai da secoli,
per capire l'Universo.
Detta così non sembra, in realtà,
così drammatica, così minacciosa,
ma pensate a questo, soltanto il 5%
di tutto quello che c'è nell'Universo
è fatto della stessa materia
di cui siamo fatti noi,
di cui sono fatti i pianeti,
di cui sono fatte le stelle,
di cui è fatto tutto quello di cui
abbiamo esperienza quotidiana,
ovvero di atomi.
La materia atomica, che a scuola
ci hanno insegnato che costituisce
tutto quello che ci circonda,
la tavola periodica, eccetera,
la materia atomica è il 5%
di quello che c'è nell'Universo.
Questo oggi lo sappiamo
con una certa accuratezza.
Quindi gli atomi sono una parte minuscola
di tutto quello che c'è nell'Universo,
il restante 95%,
quindi non una piccola parte,
ma la grande maggioranza,
è fatto di qualcosa sui cui al momento
non abbiamo nessuna certezza,
stiamo cercando di capire esattamente
che cos'è, ma non lo sappiamo.
E come complicazione aggiuntiva,
questo qualcosa che dobbiamo cercare
di studiare, di capire,
non si vede, è trasparente.
E, quindi, noi siamo un po' come uno
che volesse farsi un'idea di come è fatta
la superficie terrestre,
avendo solo immagini scattate
quando la Terra non è illuminata
direttamente dal Sole.
Vedremmo
le luci delle città,
e queste sono le cose
che hanno sempre visto gli astronomi,
le stelle,
le cose che emettono luce,
però le luci delle città
non rispecchiano fedelmente
la distribuzione della superficie emersa
della Terra,
e soprattutto ci mancherebbe completamente
l'informazione di quei grossi vuoti
che stanno in mezzo,
dove noi sappiamo che c'è l'acqua,
ma uno che invece fosse in questa
condizione difficile
non riuscirebbe a capire che lì dentro
ci sono degli oceani, c'è dell'acqua.
Per fare un paragone abbastanza calzante,
oggi la situazione degli astrofisici,
degli astronomi
e dei cosmologi,
di quelli che studiano il funzionamento
dell'Universo, è un po' questa qui.
Tutta questa cosa del lato oscuro
dell'Universo è cominciata, in realtà,
da parecchio tempo,
intorno agli anni Trenta del XX secolo.
Il primo a usare
il termine "materia oscura"
è stato questo astronomo
dal carattere piuttosto difficile
e dalle idee spesso controverse,
Fritz Zwicky.
Fritz Zwicky, negli anni Trenta
stava cercando di capire
come funzionano
oggetti di questo tipo.
Questo è un ammasso di galassie.
La maggior parte dei puntini
che vedete qui è una galassia.
Una galassia è un insieme
di centinaia di miliardi di stelle
tenute insieme dalla forza di gravità,
come la nostra Via Lattea.
In un ammasso ce ne stanno migliaia
di queste galassie
e sono anche loro tenute insieme
dalla forza di gravità.
Zwicky stava cercando di capire
come funzionavano questi oggetti,
in particolare stava cercando
di studiare il moto delle galassie.
La cosa che non ho detto
inizialmente è che, sì,
siamo in una condizione difficile,
non vediamo questa materia,
ma allora: "Come facciamo
a sapere che c'è?"
Lo sappiamo
perchè c'è la gravità:
anche questa componente oscura
dell'Universo
esercita un'influenza gravitazionale
sul resto dell'Universo
e, quindi, attraverso
lo studio della gravità
e dell'effetto che questa ha
sulla parte di Universo osservabile,
possiamo provare a farci un'idea di questa
materia che non vediamo direttamente.
Zwicky fu il primo a tentare di usare
questa tecnica, lui non sapeva ancora
che c'era la materia oscura,
cominciò ad immaginare
che c'era qualcosa che non andava,
perchè le galassie
in uno degli ammassi che stava studiando,
si muovevano troppo rapidamente
perchè ciò fosse provocato
dalla gravità della materia
che riusciva ad osservare.
Insomma, là dentro doveva esserci
molta più materia
e molta più gravità per spiegare
il moto di questi oggetti.
L'idea negli anni Trenta era
completamente assurda, fu accantonata,
e per gli astronomi dell'epoca
sembrava addirittura superflua.
Passarono diversi decenni
e la cosa ritornò a galla,
grazie al lavoro di parecchi astronomi,
in particolare al lavoro di Vera Rubin,
che stava studiando non il moto
delle galassie all'interno degli ammassi
ma il moto di singole galassie,
una galassia appunto è
un oggetto di questo tipo.
Se voi guardate una galassia così,
guardate un'immagine,
e guardate quello che riuscite a osservare
di una galassia,
vedete abbastanza chiaramente
che c'è al centro molta più luce
di quanta ce ne sia in periferia,
e così immaginate che al centro
ci siano, e infatti ci sono,
tante stelle molto dense e tenute insieme
in un nucleo abbastanza sferico e compatto
e, poi, man mano che vi allontanate
verso la periferia, la densità si dirada
e ci sono sempre meno stelle,
per cui prendendo
questa cosa per buona,
gli astronomi pensavano
che la rotazione,
l'orbita delle stelle intorno
al nucleo centrale di una galassia,
seguisse lo stesso andamento
che segue l'orbita dei pianeti
intorno al sistema solare.
Quando voi osservate
i pianeti del sistema solare,
spostandovi verso la periferia di esso,
questi si muovono sempre
più lentamente intorno al Sole
e la ragione è semplice:
la gravità laggiù è più debole
e quindi la velocità deve essere più bassa
altrimenti farebbe schizzare via
i pianeti dall'orbita.
Quindi, c'è questo andamento
decrescente della velocità.
Studiando una galassia,
anzi molte galassie di questo tipo,
Vera Rubin e altri astronomi dopo di lei,
si resero conto che la cosa invece era
completamente contraria
alle aspettative
e che le stelle
nella periferia delle galassie
ruotavano esattamente con la stessa
velocità delle stelle all'interno.
E questa cosa era assolutamente
sconcertante, sorprendente.
Per spiegare questa anomalia
nella rotazione delle galassie
si è ipotizzato, e questa è l'ipotesi
che al momento è predominante,
che le galassie siano avvolte
da un grande alone di materia trasparente,
qui l'ho disegnato io,
ovviamente non lo vediamo,
che rende conto della gravità
necessaria a spiegare il moto delle stelle
nella periferia delle galassie.
Questo ovviamente non è l'unica prova
dell'esistenza della materia oscura,
è stata la cosa che ha fatto riaccendere
l'interesse negli anni Settanta,
da quel momento in poi di prove
ne sono venute fuori a bizzeffe,
ve ne dico una, perchè il tempo è poco:
vi dico una delle più spettacolari,
che è questa e che risale a una previsione
che fece addirittura Einstein,
ovvero il fatto che anche la luce
deve risentire dell'effetto della gravità,
e, quindi, in particolare
i raggi luminosi
che passano in prossimità
di una concentrazione di massa
vengono deviati dalla gravità
di tale concentrazione.
Per cui se voi avete la vostra solita
galassia lontana, il vostro telescopio,
con cui fate l'osservazione, normalmente
vi arriva la luce in linea retta,
se tra il vostro telescopio e la galassia
mettete una certa concentrazione di massa,
per esempio un ammasso di galassie,
quello che vi aspettate di osservare,
questa era la previsione di Einstein,
è che la luce in realtà curvi
e che, dunque, riusciate a vedere
la luce delle galassie sullo sfondo,
ma distorta,
come se fosse passata
attraverso una gigantesca lente,
in effetti questo fenomeno
si chiama di "lente gravitazionale".
E questa cosa che sembra assolutamente
stupefacente, siamo riusciti ad osservarla
e ci sono prove spettacolari
come questa.
Questi archi giganteschi che vedete
sulla sinistra dell'immagine,
che formano
una specie di corona circolare,
sono proprio archi, immagini distorte
di galassie che stanno sullo sfondo,
che sono passate attraverso
una concentrazione di massa,
che in questo caso è un grosso ammasso
di galassie che sta tra noi ed esse.
Quindi attraverso questo effetto di
lente gravitazionale, voi riuscite a vedere
la materia anche dove non la vedete
con i telescopi,
se vedete delle immagini distorte
di galassie,
ovviamente dovete fare delle analisi
molto sofisticate per ottenerle,
insomma se vedete
delle immagini distorte di galassie,
sapete che tra voi e quelle galassie
c'è della concentrazione di materia,
anche se non la vedete con i telescopi.
E in questo modo negli ultimi anni,
negli ultimi decenni,
gli astronomi hanno accumulato
prove schiaccianti
del fatto che c'è molta materia oscura,
molta materia che non si vede
nell'Universo.
E che è materia del tutto diversa
da quello di cui siamo fatti noi.
Allora ci si chiede:
"Che razza di materia é?"
Questo è il problema.
Per capire di che materia si tratta
dobbiamo osservarla,
dovremmo osservarla in laboratorio,
ma questa materia, per sua stessa natura,
non solo non è visibile,
ma non interagisce col resto della materia
se non attraverso la gravità, perciò
è difficile misurarla in laboratorio.
Quello che si ipotizza è
che si tratti di particelle elementari,
non ancora osservate.
Se tale ipotesi è vera,
in questo momento, in questa stanza,
ci sono tantissime particelle
di questa materia oscura
che attraversano i muri,
i nostri corpi
ci passano accanto
e noi non ce ne accorgiamo,
e non hanno nessuna conseguenza,
ma allora: "Come fa un fisico a trovarla?"
Ci sono due strategie
che ora stiamo provando:
una è quella di mettere dei rivelatori
sotto grandi strati di roccia,
per esempio sotto al Gran Sasso,
così le particelle normali
vengono schermate
da questo enorme strato di roccia
e passano soltanto
le particelle di materia oscura,
e i rivelatori possono
sperare di catturare
qualche flebile segnale
della loro presenza;
l'altro tentativo è quello
di produrle in laboratorio,
per esempio in un acceleratore
di particelle, come l'LHC,
e di osservarle.
Una di queste due strategie,
o forse tutte e due, nei prossimi anni,
potrebbe dare qualche risultato,
nel frattempo continuiamo ad affidarci
alle osservazioni e all'astrofisica,
che ci spiegano che questa materia oscura
deve esserci,
e ci spiegano anche quant'è.
Accanto a quel 5% di atomi
che dicevamo all'inizio,
ci siamo convinti che c'è
un 23% di materia oscura nell'Universo.
Però, come vedete,
manca ancora un sacco di roba,
mancano ancora i due terzi
di tutto il contenuto di materia
ed energia dell'Universo.
In realtà, questo 70% che manca
è un mistero ancora più grande,
e per capire di che si tratta dobbiamo
tornare di nuovo indietro ad Einstein.
Dobbiamo tornare indietro al 1917,
quando Einstein tenta per la prima volta
di mettere in piedi un modello matematico
che descriva tutto l'Universo,
era una cosa che nessuno
aveva potuto mai fare prima,
lui per la prima volta aveva
gli strumenti matematici per farlo,
però, nel farlo, si accorge di una cosa:
l'Universo non può essere stabile,
perchè la gravità
è una forza attrattiva,
e la forza attrattiva di tutta la materia
che c'è nell'Universo
dovrebbe tendere
a far collassare quest'ultimo,
per cui l'Universo
non potrebbe esistere.
Einstein riflette un po' sulla cosa,
e poi tira fuori dal cilindro un trucco,
un simbolo matematico che chiama "lambda",
lo mette nelle sue equazioni,
e il significato fisico di questo simbolo
matematico è una specie di tensione
associata allo spazio vuoto,
cioè voi avete lo spazio vuoto,
c'è una tensione, la gravità cerca
di far avvicinare la materia
e la tensione dello spazio vuoto
si oppone alla gravità.
E questo termine lambda secondo Einstein
doveva servire a stabilizzare l'Universo.
Dopo qualche anno viene fuori
che l'Universo si espande,
lo scopre quel signore lì con la pipa,
Edwin Hubble,
che qui sta spiegando ad Einstein
come si usa un telescopio.
Hubble si accorge
che l'Universo si espande,
questa idea della tensione dello spazio
sembra diventare superflua,
perchè se l'Universo si espande
è l'espansione stessa a vincere la gravità
e a spiegare come fa l'Universo
ad esistere così a lungo,
e a durare così a lungo.
Einstein, in effetti, si convince e dice
che l'introduzione del termine lambda
è stato il più grande abbaglio
della sua vita.
Senonché per i decenni successivi
gli astrofisici sono convinti
che l'Universo si espande,
che la gravità frena tale espansione,
perchè la gravità è una forza attrattiva,
come abbiamo detto,
e che, dunque, quello
che dovrebbe succedere
è che questa espansione
piano piano dovrebbe rallentare.
Nel 1998, questi tre signori che, forse,
avete visto proprio questa settimana
sui giornali, perchè hanno appena vinto
il premio Nobel per la fisica,
fanno una scoperta clamorosa,
completamente sorprendente,
perché si accorgono
che l'espansione dell'Universo,
contrariamente a quello che avevano
sempre pensato gli astrofisici,
invece di decelerare,
accelera.
Cioè l'universo si espande con il tempo
sempre più velocemente,
sta accelerando in questo momento.
Come si spiega questa cosa?
Questa è la copertina di Science
del 1998,
che definisce questa scoperta
la scoperta dell'anno,
oggi sappiamo che era
non solo la scoperta dell'anno,
ma era una scoperta da Nobel,
si spiega questa osservazione resuscitando
il termine lambda di Einstein,
quindi associando di nuovo allo spazio
vuoto un'energia e una tensione
che fa accelerare
l'espansione dell'Universo.
La cosa molto interessante
di tutto questo
è che se adesso prendiamo
tale energia associata allo spazio vuoto,
il quale per definizione è trasparente,
non si vede,
quindi dobbiamo metterlo
nel conto delle cose oscure dell'Universo,
associamo questa energia e la mettiamo
nel conto che facevamo prima,
vediamo che questa ci spiega esattamente
il 72% che mancava.
Quindi siamo tutti contenti?
No, non siamo contenti
perché non abbiamo idea
di cosa sia questa energia
associata allo spazio vuoto.
Dal punto di vista teorico non c'è
un modello che ci spieghi
che cos'è questa energia
associata allo spazio vuoto
e, soprattutto, qualsiasi previsione
teorica del suo valore
dà risultati completamente sbagliati.
È, forse, una delle previsioni teoriche
più errate nella storia della fisica.
In questo momento i fisici teorici
e i cosmologi stanno cercando di capire
non solo quello che già creava problemi,
ovvero che cos'è la materia oscura,
ma hanno questo ulteriore problema
da risolvere,
cioè il problema dell'energia oscura,
come viene chiamata
con grande spreco di fantasia.
Vi dico soltanto uno
dei tentativi di spiegazione
che è stato avanzato negli ultimi tempi
e che va molto di moda recentemente.
L'idea è che il nostro Universo
sia soltanto uno
fra un numero enorme, addirittura
forse infinito di altri universi,
e che in ognuno di questi universi,
questa energia associata allo spazio vuoto
abbia un valore completamente diverso
e casuale.
E che, quindi, non c'è
sostanzialmente niente da spiegare,
perchè noi viviamo in un universo
che ha un valore
che ha consentito all'espansione
di andare avanti per 13,7 miliardi di anni
e questa cosa incidentalmente
ha dato anche la possibilità
alla vita intelligente di svilupparsi
e a noi di stare qui a farci domande
sull'energia oscura,
ma in altri universi
le cose potrebbero essere andate
in maniera completamente diversa.
Quindi secondo questo modo di ragionare
non c'è niente da spiegare,
perchè è come chiedersi perchè il nostro
pianeta ha acqua liquida in superficie.
La ragione è che se non avesse
acqua liquida in superficie,
non saremmo qui,
e quindi noi possiamo soltanto trovarci
in un pianeta che ha
acqua liquida in superficie.
Questa spiegazione
fa storcere il naso a molti,
ma è una delle spiegazioni possibili.
Quel che è certo è che siamo in un momento
veramente molto eccitante,
per chi cerca di studiare l'Universo.
Come diceva qualcuno, quando la confusione
è grande sotto il cielo,
in questo caso quando la confusione
è grande in cielo,
la situazione è eccellente.
Soprattutto per noi che dobbiamo cercare
di capire come vanno le cose.
Grazie.
(Applausi)